I need a break Kaldur you me Wally we we
founded this team without him I
understand
business as usual
all right
[Music]
all right all right I'm coming this is
cat grant reporting live from the
Markovian royal palace Mehta human
trafficking is an international scourge
children and teens are being abducted
the way our daughter was abducted
there's a meta human trafficking
syndicate markovia that we can shut down
with your help when it's all over we go
our separate ways no muss no fuss
Prince Bo you tested positive for the
meta-gene princess Tara would likely
have tested positive as well which
explains why she was taken
something daring must be done if I have
to save markovia
letyagin activated let's see what we've
got
he seems ticked off ticked
[Music]
young justice season 3 trailer everybody
we are officially whelmed so let's break
this down so they started with a sizzle
reel from the past couple of seasons I
cut that way down because it was just
catching people up on what happened
during season 1 and season 2 if you're
finding me for the first time be sure to
subscribe to get all the comic-con
videos it's only gonna get crazier today
tomorrow and there's so much stuff
coming up so I'll try to explain what's
going on with the release date because
we have the DC Universe streaming
service stuff and I know people outside
of the United States would want to know
when they're gonna be able to get it -
there's a new round of that flash ring
giveaway - all you have to do to enter
is be a subscriber and leave a comment
on the video the first real footage of
season 3 is with Artemis in bed grieving
over Wally tried to move on with her
life they were very tight-lipped about
what the exact time jump is going to be
but I believe it's 5 years because that
was the time jump between season 1 and
season 2 they've aged up a bunch of this
and it's been about 5 years in real life
since season 2 went off the air but
because they delay the season 3 premiere
til next year it will have been closer
to six years since season 2 went off so
it won't be quite as pretty as that that
might be why they're being tight-lipped
about it it seems like a weird thing to
keep under wraps but as you can tell
from this trailer the whole idea of
season 3 is the world weaponizing the
metahuman gene they were inspired a lot
by The Outsiders comics so you've
probably spotted a couple Outsiders
characters that I'll explain as we get
to the footage here but the first big
adventure that you showed in the trailer
is is that princess markovia is found to
have the metahuman gene so she gets
kidnapped they have to go rescue her
that's like their first big mission but
as these characters are experiencing
this they've been at this for a while so
Nightwing says one last mission then
we'll go our separate ways so you have
Superboy Nightwing black lightning going
to rescue Terra this is geo force he's
confirmed to be part of the season you
saw him on the poster this other person
on the poster is confirmed to be halo
she's an original character from The
Outsiders and this bug light character
is actually forager he's a New Gods
character like you see Orion later in
the trailer so there is new god stuff
going on if Darkseid is gonna be one of
the big villains then of course the new
gods are going to be part of season 3 to
love Superboy vs Lobo wonder if we're
ever going to get a live action movie
with Lobo
this is sensei he's a Batman villain
this next person is black spider make
all the spider-man jokes that you want
he's also a Batman villain new costume
for static Metamorpho they're couple
Justice League characters like Batman
and Barry Allen that show up during this
but obviously the focus is on the Young
Justice characters
yeah Bart's new design he still has that
sense of humor but he's quite a bit
older the interesting thing about that
too is that they say that the forger
character brings levity that Wally
brought in the first couple of seasons
they didn't say anything about Wally
coming back but I think we're all
wondering how that's going to happen new
shots of katana this is another new
character her name is 13 or Tracy 13
sees a magic based character this is
arrow wet because Artemis is still going
to be the tigress character during
season 3 there's also a character called
red arrow that'll be part of the season
2 so a lot of arrow based characters
then new shots of Vandal Savage because
the light is still very much the big
villain of the series and now they
formed an alliance with the forces of
apocalypse so you have to imagine that
they're like the really big villains
behind all this pulling strings there's
26 episodes total when people on the
panel ask them when international people
will be able to watch the episodes
because we know we're getting them early
ish 2019 in the United States people are
like what about everyone else outside of
the United States they were also very
confused so it sounds like they're still
figuring that out but people did ask the
DC Universe people that are managing
this platform
what's going on with stuff outside the
United States they said that they're
trying to perfect the bugs in the app
before they roll it out internationally
so they haven't confirmed it but they're
making it sound like they will make the
DC Universe app available
internationally but if that doesn't
happen then I think that Netflix will
probably wind up being the International
distributor for all this stuff but
that's still a theory right now they're
probably waiting for the beta to launch
in August and find out what goes wrong
with it like if there's any huge bugs
then fixing that stuff then deciding how
they're gonna roll stuff out
internationally they confirmed that they
have seven episodes in the can as of
right now Comic Con so that might also
be a reason for the delay because they
still have a bunch of stuff to finish on
other episodes all the voice recording
was finished a while ago most of the
animation is done but there's still just
so many things that you have to do to
get animation out so it's probably part
of the reason for the delay because we
have all the Titans stuff going on in
the DC Universe too
they did say obviously Teen Titans still
very big characters inside the world of
young justice but there is no official
Teen Titans team within the series but
you will see those characters like Tim
Drake of course you've seen some of the
new costumes most of the characters do
get new character designs with the
exception to Blue Beetle who still it's
just the same scarab but like you have
Stephanie Brown spoiler cassie sandsmark
is back her costume isn't that different
Bart's is probably one of the biggest
changes because now he kind of looks
like wall-e so I know everybody's gonna
be a little triggered post all your
reactions in the comments below let me
know if you have any specific questions
to like they didn't answer every single
question on the panel and they didn't
give away any big spoilers or anything
like that so we the way nobody's getting
new young justice episodes till early
next year at the earliest because it was
originally supposed to premiere at the
end of the year but then I think they
delayed the launch by a couple months so
Titans isn't premiering till a little
bit later and they want to air all the
Titans episodes before they launch the
Young Justice episodes so don't worry I
will do new videos as we learn new
information but leave all your requests
in the comments below
Saturday is really like the Superbowl of
DC trailers we have the Aquaman trailer
there's a Sue's am trailer there's all
the other DC TV trailers so as long as
you have alerts enabled for my channel
you'll see all the videos there's a new
venom trailer that's probably going to
post later tonight too so of course lots
of spider-man lots of DC stuff coming in
the next couple of days wait wait for
everything click here to watch Robin
drop more f-bombs and click here for
brand new Avengers 4 thank you so much
for watching everybody stay whelmed I
will see you guys tonight
[Music]